welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast I'm Gus Docker I'm here with
Mariana senko who is the co-founder of
future Ventures which is a venture
capital firm so Mariano welcome to the
podcast
much for having me
okay perhaps we could start by talking
about how Venture Capital Works where
does it fit on say the spectrum of risk
from a pension fund to a private
investment
action in the in the market and I think
it's probably not the right framing to
say where does it sit on on the wrist
because frankly lots of Pension funds
invest in lots of venture capital funds
and so
um there's a little bit of a stacked
hierarchy here
I think when when people think about an
Investment Portfolio they think about
low risk and probably frankly low yield
opportunities and high very high risk
but hopefully high yield opportunities
and venture capital is about a far on
the right side of that high risk high
yield as you could probably reasonably
get
um it's like you know maybe one tick
below gambling
um with frankly about the same
statistical odds
and so in a diversified portfolio one
might hope for uh some small portion of
the portfolio to be distributed across
any one of these particular access
points across this risk yield profile
and so uh Venture Capital ends up being
within the portfolio management scheme
of many different types of investing
bundles and firms but the best way to
think about Venture capitalists and
venture capital is that we
take very high risk hopefully high yield
for our investors chances
um and that from an entrepreneurial
standpoint you know we we're we're
capable of funding things that possibly
nobody else would touch with a 10-foot
Pole
and the the flip side of that is that
our cost of capital is a fair bit higher
than what you might eventually come to
as you come down that risk curve right
so Venture Capital tends to make the
most sense at the earliest stages of an
idea to kind of test it against reality
because there there which you would
expect the returns to be high if it
succeeds and you would expect a lot of
things to fail at the early stage that's
right in fact that's the vast majority
of things fail
and so why is this an interesting place
to invest why why do we need the Venture
Capital industry why couldn't we just
say for example have existing firms
existing large corporations like apple
and Microsoft do the things that Venture
Capital capitalists try to do it's
fascinating question right there's been
a number of books written on this
construction
um this construct of the the innovators
dilemma
um as it's a Well referred to and I
think essentially there's an
there's a set point and it's not clear
to me that it's always true it just
seems to be almost always true that at a
certain size stage cultural profile of a
corporation
Innovation and creativity effectively
falls off a cliff
and part of it is that it's hard and
expensive to really throw new ideas at
the wall and see what sticks and they're
for very brief periods of time large
corporations can actually occasionally
pull this off and exam wonderful
examples of this are like the Bell Labs
uh situation but they they tend to not
last very long and frankly not that many
things come out of them
um that actually
push forward into reality but Bell Labs
again being
um a historical counter example but even
if we look at our friends at alphabet
you know Google has endeavored so many
times over the years and poured so much
Capital into
trying to build novel beautiful Hardware
products and yet we're not all walking
around with Google Glass on our heads
and with some type of functional robot
helping us out at home
and
I've wondered this myself deeply right
why why do you actually need constraints
to push through that that through line
of of innovation and creativity like if
you look at the Dow Jones Industrial
Average two-thirds of companies on the
Dow Jones Industrial Average were
started in recessions
right so perhaps that's a marker for us
to think about perhaps what you actually
need to really be pushing the bleeding
edge of a particular type of innovation
is to be so wildly constrained that you
actually have to come up with such a
novel way of doing something I'm not
saying all creativity comes from
startups that's obviously not true right
like the wood apple is doing incredible
work on antenna design and
tsmc is so good at manufacturing really
incredible chips that our entire world
is based off of and as far as I can tell
no startup is like going to really you
know figure out how to rip semiconductor
manufacturing out from the big players
so there are certain things that are
absolutely relegated to the world of
large corporations but there's a style
and aesthetic of early stage creation
idea product development that seems to
just move much faster inside smaller
leaner companies and why why can't this
structure of the Venture Capital fund or
the startup be replicated inside of
existing companies I know a lot of
existing companies have tried this but
it to me it doesn't seem to have
succeeded wildly at least so why why
can't they replicate the startup
environment inside of existing companies
I I love this question and I
was at some point in my uh prior
existence at Airbus
um and before that was a a consultant to
a number of large corporations thinking
about autonomous systems
and Robotics and in autonomous vehicles
and I don't have a tight answer on this
because like theoretically it should be
possible but I think at the end of the
day it's really hard to maintain that
style of ambition and frankly delusion
inside a large comfortable Corporation
right so it's when when your lunch is
beautifully served to you uh in a
stunning cafeteria with thousands of
your other colleagues and everyone's
kind of plugging away at a small piece
of a large puzzle it's hard to maintain
a small team that actually feels
existential pressure and it's a fair
question which is like do we actually
need to feel like an existential threat
like our capacity to not exist tomorrow
to actually get through these early days
inside startups and I don't love this
because as like ostensibly a person who
practices like Buddhist styles of
thought I'm like oh man do we really
have to create suffering to have output
like that's such an unfortunate
construct to believe in right though
like do you actually have to
um generate like fear and concern and
suffering
um to get
to tightly iterate on products quickly
sufficiently but I think what ends up
being hap what ends up happening is that
large companies have
so many things that they have to worry
about that setting up a Cadence
internally
or maybe even with some reference
reference points externally that say
okay you know here's a bit of capital
get to these milestones uh and then only
then will we give you more capital for
you to continue
and I think that's just hard to do with
within within an employee pool uh you
know it's it's frankly probably hard
from an HR standpoint uh because the
simple reality is basically startups are
on the chopping block every 12 to 18
months did deterministically trying to
figure out whether or not anyone wants
to continue supporting them yeah we
should we should dive a little deeper
into this these statistics that you've
been alluding to so when we talk about
most startups failing what does this
mean for example if we take a a typical
VC fund how many of their investments
will succeed and to what extent will
they will they succeed so how many will
succeed wildly how many will totally
fail how many will become mediocre
um yeah how's the landscape looking oh
yeah you know
it's one of these
symmetric outcomes so there there's this
construct called the the power law which
suggests that basically your your top
performing investment will overshadow
all other Investments that you've made
cumulatively right so and then if you're
good then your second best investment
overshadows everything underneath that
cumulatively right to the point where
it's not that you have one winner and
everything else dies but effectively
when you think about the that kind of
curve
the area under the curve right goes down
exponentially and so you end up
effectively from a perspective that
the gain you have from a small
investment doing marginally okay like
maybe a 2X
is so overshadowed by a top investment
doing orders of magnitude better than
that that it's all like effectively
everything else could like could be a
zero and it basically wouldn't matter
you know how many Venture funds are
actually 10x Venture funds frankly not
that many how many Venture funds across
the pool of all venture capital firms
actually have spectacular returns again
not that many right like the top 10
percent of venture funds return have 90
of the gains in the market so there's
also like the small pool of players
within Venture Capital who are doing
very well so there's almost like a power
law of venture capital firms also there
are and what's interesting about that is
it's actually there's a group called
correlation Ventures
um that has some interesting statistics
on this that that actually suggests that
even more so than the Venture funds it's
the actual in individuals doing the
Investments and so that even even within
Venture funds it's it's actually like
which partner you had at which firm uh
is is probably the best correlative of
overall success rather than even just
the Top Line name brand of the firm
so you know when I say something like 90
of per of companies that want any given
venture capitalist might invest in um or
effectively
but not good investments in the same way
it's not that they all go to zero it's
not that those companies die in fact
mostly they return
maybe the the original capital so you
generally try not to lose money right um
but you how many of your potential
Investments actually return a 5 or 10 or
20x uh certainly less than 10 and
frankly about one percent so in a
portfolio in any given fund we would
invest in
um 20 companies out of each novel fund
that we raise of which we would we would
hope that one ideally would be an
absolute moonshot outstanding winner
uh and then hopefully there's another
one underneath that and hopefully
another one underneath that but right it
follows that that parallel line
um but our Our Hope also at the same
time is to ensure that
every single one of our investments
gets to fruition in the sense that we
really we try to invest in things that
we think the world fundamentally needs
and so I also care deeply about not
seeing anything die just for the sake of
it um but to actually say can we find a
soft landing spot maybe in a large
company
uh maybe adjacent to some other
organization where we ensure that this
idea and this team and this thing
actually comes to fruition uh even if
it's not right like if I was just
economically motivated frankly I should
have become an investment banker yeah I
can I can see the attraction of venture
capital investing from the investor side
but say that that a a bright-eyed young
person comes to you and has an idea and
of course you as you said maybe they are
delusionally confident in their idea and
this is I'm assuming that you would want
them to to say this is the idea that's
going to change the world if they said
looking at the statistical nature of the
statistical landscape in these see
investing I predict that I will probably
not succeed I mean then you would then
you would probably pass on that
investment you want everyone to believe
that they are they are the ones who will
succeed wildly
um is there some
from from the people who are starting
the startups is there something perhaps
against their own interest here that
that the that they are expected to be to
be extremely uh perhaps overconfident in
in their own Vision uh for them to be
taken seriously well let me let me try
to better understand that question
they need to
hurt and that's a net negation or that
that form of personality is like a
baseline requirement perhaps that that's
that it's a baseline requirement and
could it could it be so I so could it be
good for the investor but perhaps bad
for for the people trying
oh I love this question
the companies that we try to invest in
right we invest in early stage deep
technology companies that we hope will
make the world better and more verdant
place and ideally more peaceful and and
more equitable
and not prey on human Frailty what we
find is we invest in the kinds of
entrepreneurs who say
this just has to exist and it's killing
me that it doesn't and I'm looking
around and nobody else is picking up
this ball
so
it's not that you want The Reluctant
entrepreneur because you actually want
someone deeply motivated to go build
this thing but you want the person who
is just
it's a vocation it's a calling it's a
deep intrinsic need in their being to
see this become reality
and I think when that happens there's
actually a humility that shows up
because it's not just about them wearing
a badge of like look what a successful
entrepreneur I am and you know the
number of people who equate success to
the number of dollars they've raised
like that's that's not success that's
just Your Capacity to tell a very good
story that's necessary but certainly not
sufficient
but there's a humility that comes with
saying I am in service to this idea
and I've willingly stepped into the ring
to figure out how to make it real and I
am in service to the idea to the other
people I bring along to commit to
bringing this into fruition and so we
actually find that the most incredible
entrepreneurs are the ones who have a
particular form of humility they have
maybe extreme technical courage right
the capacity to say this is really hard
nobody's ever done this but we have deep
faith in ourselves our team our
technical capacities you know our
ability to build a nuclear fusion
reactor so on that aspect they do have
to have that perspective of a
willingness to say no we're gonna go
figure out how to build reusable Rockets
even though nobody's ever done it before
and at the same time a capacity to pause
and iterate and actually take real
feedback
um because I think anyone who's driven
to any personality poll
ends up you end up boss balance and then
all sorts of probably frightening things
happen personally and professionally
yep so we should also perhaps say that
we're talking about companies uh
succeeding or failing here we could have
repeat tries so from the from the person
trying to start these companies they
could try a second time or a third time
how how common is that that you see a
first-time startup uh entrepreneur fail
and then come back and and succeed
what I see more commonly
is
a a startup with a moderate bit of
success perhaps the entrepreneur
personally had a life-changing financial
event as a result of that
you know that what what we would
consider a moderate outcome like good
job you 5x this investment thank you for
not losing your money thank you for
making us a fair bit of capital more
importantly thank you for bringing this
idea into fruition
um and then maybe the company sells to
some other company that large
corporation that hopefully continues to
see the idea forward most often we see
those entrepreneurs coming back around
and saying I've really learned my
lessons
I didn't build a multi-generation all
multi-billion dollar massive
organization in fact I got swallowed up
by one of those but now I know what I
what I'm going to do different I think a
lot of people who struggle in their
first go around absolutely do come
around I wish more of them took more
time off right so I see a lot of people
jumping from one idea
to another or trying to Pivot within the
same company and I think that can work
and obviously it has worked in in quite
a number of cases but I think it's also
important to to pause and figure out how
to reset and refresh so I when I do meet
entrepreneurs
um I was actually just having dinner
with um a brilliant uh former CEO Who
Sold her company and she she hired an
executive coach after selling her
company
to help her ensure that she wouldn't
just immediately start the next company
that is a massively motivated individual
that's that's I don't think that's a
problem that a lot of people have that
they can't hold themselves back and
perhaps that's exactly the type of
person you're looking I think
entrepreneurs do have this problem I
think like entrepreneurship is like this
communicable disease right you can't
like once they get in it and and I think
it's also like it's like childbirth like
you you don't actually remember the pain
of it you just remember the euphoria
uh and and so maybe that's also some
something that happens here which is
that people go through it and depending
on their experience They Don't Really
tap out instead they're like I need more
of that
I would imagine that if people
won moderately so as you mentioned maybe
5x the original investment and and we're
now they're comfortable I would imagine
perhaps that they would become a little
lazier or not be motivated to do
anything but that that's not what you
see you you see that they they
immediately jump to the next thing and
try again to start something truly
revolutionary
I think what happens
um you know ideally they take some time
off and they deep time with their family
and they figure out what is going to be
a sustainable pace for their life but I
think when you get outside of the scope
of being fiscally Tethered to your
reality right we're we're a particular
Baseline outcome is an absolute
necessity for your continued happy
healthy existence
there's a different thing that happens
on the other side of that right when you
when you're talking to a person who's
who's maybe not entirely but perhaps
largely post-economic you end up in
conversations with people who are really
asking like what needs to come into
being
and how can I best position myself to be
of service to that and I find that those
are some of the Most Fascinating People
because it's
it's no longer a job it's a calling
and I think what startups force you to
recognize is that if you don't at any at
any question right like any bright
person working at any startup frankly at
any level like forget this it's the
founders
um you know early teams included they
you have to ask yourself this question
of
it's difficult and largely thankless and
the payout may never come so you really
need to be motivated by the mission of
the original
of of the thesis of the work
and if you're not you probably shouldn't
be there
and so I think that that ideology
becomes even more true uh as people move
through through their careers and and
varying stages of life
do you think that if you had a VC fund
that didn't have a high failure rate
call it failure if if it does if the
startups do not succeed wildly so so
if you had a VC fund that didn't have
this power law distribution would this
imply to you that you weren't being
ambitious enough so would it mean that
you weren't taking on very weird bits
um that turn out to be great companies
10 years later
yeah we were actually we we were just
closing the fundraise on our third fund
we're actually have now closed it
um certainly we'll have closed it by the
time this podcast goes live and
um we had a couple folks who were
talking to us who essentially said you
know why aren't more companies in your
portfolio dead
well I thought you guys were you know on
the leading and bleeding edge
and our response was don't worry they're
still going to die
um and a lot of it was just that we
we've lived um particularly 2021 was a
very strange year of
a lot of capital floating around in the
markets and
now that
globally interest rates are on the rise
uh
things like early stage high-risk Tech
investing uh probably look a little less
compelling there's probably a little
less capital in the market
um
more things will suffer going forward
than than probably have in the last
couple of years even modulo covid
so yeah I I fundamentally think that if
you are purporting to position yourself
as an early stage investor and you're
not seeing some significant level of
attrition then perhaps you haven't
crawled out to the furthest edge of the
branch that
maybe you should be this is in a sense a
very hardcore environment to be in where
this is the this is the measure of
whether you're succeeding is that uh a
lot of your portfolio companies are
failing that's right
I'm fascinated by VC I'm fascinated by
the by this kind of hit based investing
another thing that's fascinating about
the industry is the is the long time
Horizons so perhaps you could talk a
little bit about this because it it
seems unique to me
um perhaps
long time Horizons like this show up in
academic research but you don't see you
don't see long time Horizons in publicly
traded companies at least not to the
same extent I think perhaps tell us a
bit a bit about time Horizons in in VC
and and you know
you know term Stock Exchange
perhaps we
overall eventually shift people to a
mindset of thinking over the longer Arc
um but that's that's frankly quite
difficult for people to do uh it's
doesn't it's not structurally set up
appropriately in most of our
corporations right we most people take a
job particularly if you look across
societal structures today there are very
few countries left on earth like Japan
where there's an expectation of you've
took in this job and you're going to
work here for the next 30 Years right
like the it's beautiful that that
continues to exist there that is very
much not the way of the broader rest of
the the world or the the direction that
the world has taken and so there's this
question of saying well what does it
look like to actually build the future
world and frankly I think that the vast
majority of people in Venture Capital
who invest in Enterprise software and
consumer social media plays or whatever
actually aren't operating on a
particularly long Horizon right there's
there's a strong push of saying you have
to get to
um profitability in
two years and then hyperscale growth in
a handful of years after that
um and the internet really under rode
that trend for a long time and then even
post the.com crash it's been kind of
this enterprise software investing where
there is a strong push to say
okay you you don't actually have
that many years to get to a sustainable
business the kinds of companies we
invest in we recognize that we have to
be a little bit more patient right you
you can't actually build a rocket ship
that eventually becomes a marsh
transporter that has a successful launch
business in a short order number of
years SpaceX has been around for quite a
while
and we're as a venture fund we're a
15-year fund which means that
um our we hope to return Capital to our
investors before 15 years but that we
won't wrap up the fund short of 15 years
so that's that's kind of this the
starting point and the construct here is
here is that to invest in these kind of
deep Tech often you know physical most
of our investments actually have a
software underlay that allows for a
computational advancement
but we recognize that these fundamental
technology plays just take a bit longer
to mature and that we want to be honest
about what that actually looks like that
said we actually don't think that
businesses should be funded purely on
Venture dollars for decades on end it's
about recognizing that you have to
figure out how to get to a place of
iterating early with customers or the
market in some way and then right and
then over the long Arc recognizing that
it can take a decade to really build
that business into its full fruition and
that's when you as an early investor you
know you kind of want to keep supporting
and piling in I think there's a bit of a
there's a difference here which is we
don't expect liquidity in two to three
years we expect progress and growth
and that's the difference of the mindset
versus
um you know a shareholder in the public
market that's the whole thing about
public markets they're liquid you can
actually move those positions private
markets you can't move those the
valuations are much more stable in fact
the companies are more stable but
they're they're stable because you can't
get out of them
I think you're fixed
and so we we need both right we need
short-term liquidity and we need
long-term belief systems is it perhaps
tempting to go to these software as a
service Investments that can scale over
the internet and return investment
dollars quickly do you think that's uh
it's tempting to to do that for for a
lot of funds as opposed to to thinking
more long term and thinking perhaps
creating a hardware
that's what 90 probably nine percent I
don't know I don't actually know how
many funds are out there right now what
they're focusing on but the vast
majority of funds focus on that and I
don't blame them for a second
I just wouldn't be able to sleep at
night if that's the thing that I focused
on
um and it's not from a place of moral
outrage of what others are doing it's
from a perspective of what is the
leverage point that I would like to have
on reality and what would I like to see
to come into fruition like we're trying
to fund the kinds of companies that
history books will be written about
and frankly I just don't think that many
history books are going to be written
about
some of these very frankly really
important you know underlying software
systems but
helping some marketing team manage uh
their client portal is just I mean I'm
asleep before I even manage to watch the
rest of the sentence but then but to
someone else that's deeply exciting
right uh and so it's just about asking
like
are you at your best and highest use
supporting the things that you're trying
to support
how do you think about getting feedback
on how the companies are doing if you're
investing over very long at a long time
Horizons because you you want I think
you mentioned earlier you want to
iterate quickly you want to perhaps
change course if what you're doing is
not working uh I I don't imagine that
you wait 15 years and then see how
things are are doing but but you know
how do you how do you think about
feedback over long time Horizons oh God
I love this question
so we try to take take on more
engineering risk and less underlying
fundamental science risk because
where do you draw the arbitrary Line in
the Sand to say that a particular piece
of scientific research is now concrete
and sufficient to build an entire
product Suite around it we should
distinguish these two so so what's the
difference between fundamental science
risk and Engineering risk is are we
talking about whether something is
physically possible here's an example I
think we would be very very reticent to
invest in a novel battery chemistry
without seeing an actual
cylindrical cell likely on a desktop
in a lab stage with a question of what
is the charge what is the discharge rate
what is the hysteresis Loop what is a
full life cycle analysis of this battery
right so basically not going to bet on
someone's battery chemistry until they
show me that they can manufacture at
least one cell
and that probably precludes me from
frankly investing in any novel battery
chemistry like as a whole because I just
have this arbitrary Line in the Sand of
saying I think this is the choke point
and I don't know how you get past that
choke point with
you know positive
um
without frankly investing an awful lot
of money quantum computers are another
perfect example we didn't invest in any
gate model computers because we
basically said well it's going to cost a
couple hundred million dollars to build
the First full gate system and any
transient piece on the way to that
doesn't actually say a lot about whether
or not the Holgate model works
versus we invested in a nuclear fusion
company which should probably cause you
to scratch your head and say wait a
second yeah only did you do battery
chemistry but you did nuclear fusion
like what is wrong with you
um but the difference there is we really
came to confidence that we invest in
Commonwealth Fusion systems that a
tokamax system will work and it's a
question of at what scale and how
powerful a plasma and the the the cost
of the entire system and the energy
output is directly related
um to the size of the plasma and your
capacity to basically have a high
density plasma is driven entirely by the
strength of your electromagnet not
entirely there's a number of other
things involved but one could make the
simple correlation that if you could
build a magnet that's significantly more
powerful than any other electromagnet on
Earth then you can have a denser plasma
higher output smaller building the math
closes suddenly and so when we met a
company that said we're going to
eventually do this thing of building
tokamax that's largely proven and the
thing that we need to figure out is
whether or not we can first make and
then second manufacture these magnets
that was an inflection point for us
where we said that we can underwrite
because there's a clear inflection point
around which I think we believe that a
scientifically sound
set of reasoning can be built and so
that's kind of where we think is like is
there a known testable
empirically referenceable decision point
that you can come to to say this is
working or not working and
this is where like a lot of Biotech and
biomedical decisions are really hard
because you have like these soft
clinical endpoints or you have a
situation where you say
okay it didn't work inside a sample size
of 10.
but is that enough of an experiment to
say with statistical accuracy that it's
not working
well I don't know do you need to run it
100 times 200 times and what is the cost
of doing that right so it's like always
the sliding scale of saying at which
point do I gain confidence
so you're looking for a prototype or a
proof of concept something that's that's
actually been built but that's does that
exclude you from the very wildest and
perhaps most interesting Investments you
could make that are that are at the
stage before the Prototype is even
created does it make sense to think even
further out so perhaps at a 30-year
timeline or is that simply beyond the
the capacity of the Investment Systems
we have now I don't think that there's a
direct correlation between
stage of technological maturity or
technology Readiness level or either TRL
level and in a in a linear time
Construction
and again I think it's all about pricing
risk to some extent so for example we
invested in an ammonia catalysis company
on the basis of belief system that we
have the hammer Bosch process was
effectively last significantly you know
iterated on when it was developed in the
early 1900s
effectively the entirety of our Global
Food system is based on it right ammonia
the vast majority of ammonia that is
generated goes into fertilizer turns out
we need an awful lot of fertilizer we
can have a whole different conversation
about whether or not that's the right
way and whether or not we should be
using
um uh different agents and to to
reaffirm soil structures but it's it's
one of these it's one of these
scientific technologies that that
underlie our civilization where no one
has even really heard about it but it it
brings the food on the table every day
correct right and to any one of your
listeners highly recommend Alchemy of
the
surprisingly
and I didn't ever think I would say that
about a book about ammonia but the
question of
um you know how early are we willing to
go and at what point like this
entrepreneur came to us and said I don't
have a better catalyst
but I have a strategy around using a
particular form of computational
modeling that I think will help us
derive
a pathway to creating better catalysis
process not just for Haber Bosch but
potentially across the entire catalysis
landscape and and I want to go explore
that and we wrote the first check into
the company saying yeah absolutely that
is reasonable because frankly the
iteration is pretty cheap right it's
compute Cycles and fast and then we can
down select to things that we actually
go and bring into like the wet lab
chemistry setup so
I'm very comfortable investing at a
stage that's outrageously early if
there's a commentary
that suggests
that the speed of experimentation is for
some reason accelerated because the last
thing that you want to do is invest on
some necessary novel future Innovation
but no inflection point about why you
might arrive at that next inflection
point faster than anyone has done it in
the past or cheaper or more efficiently
ideally all of those things right faster
cheaper more efficiently they all kind
of Stack and so you need to you you need
if you're going to
be presenting something at the earliest
stages of Investigation I think there
also needs to be a story about why that
investigation is going to be more
efficient when we talk about deep Tech
I'm thinking of of nuclear fusion for
example I'm thinking of rockets
something that changes uh something
physical in the world and not just
pixels on a screen but do you think that
a lot of deep Tech involves uh software
also so is is there is there a sense in
which
deepseek is not it's a sense in which
hardware and software is merging
together because as you just mentioned
the some of these innovations that
affect the physical world come out of
machine learning for example uh deepmind
had a breakthrough where they used again
machine learning to to yeah help with uh
with the an advance in nuclear fusion
and so you see these two uh you see
software and Hardware coming together in
interesting ways does it make sense to
split the world into the physical and
and software anymore
no um and frankly I don't think it ever
did and to our friends at a16z who you
know at some point said software is
eating the world and now are investing
in an awful lot of kind of Hardware tech
companies that I think even the most
stringent supporters of everything
exists in a software layer are
recognizing that at the end of the day
we're pretty three-dimensional beings
that doesn't matter how compelling the
metaverse becomes we're we're still
going to move bits around and
but but I also think it's an unfair
delineation in the other direction which
is to say that things that exist in in
free space and the atoms bits Hardware
world and
um that they're not entirely dependent
and enmeshed in the software space right
so
this this construction of
how can we use software simulation uh
predictive systems Transformers large
language models whatever
the the you know topic du jour is in
novel software architecture and
development to help our capacity to
iterate faster and more efficiently in
physical space because what we need to
get away from is how slow and clunky and
exceptionally costly it is
to actually do things in the physical
world right like just just picture
this case which is what if you could
have a full
biological digital twin of yourself like
you Gus as a human right with all of
your ancestral familial genetic data and
all of your relevant like blood levels
and markers and you know food allergens
like set up as but not by the creation
of like creating a child and seeing what
immune system they have in the world and
actually saying
what if we could actually recreate that
digitally
and then basically run models forward
and backward and say well How likely are
you to develop a particular type of
cancer and what inputs might you want to
change to shift that right I think
the the addition of
deep computational models will
fundamentally shift how we move forward
in the world our capacity to have truly
personalized medicine
and we're just at the most nascent stage
of that today
um but I'm so excited basically about
figuring out how these how these two
spaces in our mesh do you think that you
could potentially replace the Venture
Capital industry by huge Innovation
prices so for example say instead of we
instead of having Venture capitalists
pick out startup Founders that are
trying to solve nuclear fusion we put up
a billion dollar price to any team that
solves nuclear fusion or that gets out
net energy from from a from a nuclear
fusion process sure but who funds
I mean those exist right the X prizes
exist and they're not billion dollar
prizes but
tons that Fusion company getting to
a prize you're going to need a billion
dollars to build their first reactor
we can change the numbers around and we
we could say perhaps it's a it's
actually a hundred million dollars for
it to make economic sense but there is
some some um
interesting idea in which you you
incentivize people of course to try to
innovate here but perhaps you have a lot
of different teams spending more than
the total price in trying to win the
price and so perhaps you you it's an
efficient way to get what you want but
is it really I mean I'm gonna push you
on that because one again who funds the
work because it's you
like let's let's use literally any
industry
um let's say electric vehicles right so
someone could have funded the electric
vehicle prize but it costs an awful lot
of money to go build an electric vehicle
and then test vehicles and then
eventually build a consumer vehicle that
might get to a point of wanting to win
one of those prizes who funds that I
don't have a great answer for that I I
admit so perhaps perhaps you would need
to venture capitalists to fund a lot of
firms and so right
is winning the public market the
prize-winning consumer sentiment and use
case and Industry and becoming the de
facto standard of the future so you
don't actually need the the carrot is
not the question like the carrot already
exists the carrot is we have to figure
out how to live
functionally on this planet
in concert with our ecosystems with
other humans and then maybe eventually
on other planets as well
that carrot is huge
and there's no need for a prize the
question is and the the other way that
you could say this like if I if I took
your construct of a question to a lot
it's logical reality I think you hit up
against a pretty strong social fallacy
which is then
there is no Equitable Pathway to a
bright kid sitting somewhere in the
world to go and start an idea because
you're basically saying
there's future prize but no access to
current capital and so the only people
who can actually work on those things
are
top universities a handful of wealthy
billionaires people who are entirely
post-economic so we'd really be
shrinking the pool set of who has the
capacity to go do these things because
no one's going to do work for anyone
else on the promise of like maybe one
day we future win some big thing I take
your point I totally take your point
um I am so I'm interested in venture
capital and I'm interested in in which
lessons we so author areas of life could
take from mentor capital for example
what could the philanthropy industry if
we can call it that learn from from
Venture Capital specifically is there
other interesting lessons relating to
this hit-based investing and and
long-time Horizons perhaps are people
not being ambitious enough in
philanthropy
interesting question
um I struggled to put venture capital on
a pedestal of saying that it is the best
or most efficient way to bring ideas
into being it
it has a particular use case and for
things
for first for keys right companies that
fit the keyhole of venture capital like
when those two things mate it's
incredible and everyone passed
themselves on the back and the world is
better faster hopefully occasionally
worse faster and then we have to deal
with the Fallout of that
um and to your earlier question I think
there will be a lot of things that will
probably bear out a significant ShakeOut
in the Venture market so it's not that I
think that we're
so intrinsically necessary that there
isn't a world moving forward without us
we're just we we sit at an interesting
inflection point
as a person who participates in
philanthropy there there are different
kinds there are different ways to look
at philanthropic gains right
um and I would
question whether like where learnings
from Venture Capital would carry over so
um I think in terms like an interesting
question to ask is basically like what
is the most
efficient spend of dollars for largest
outcomes and so turns out
um
in the climate space client Earth uh is
a is a
I believe it's a non-profit is is
focused on
helping adjudicate
climate policies in the courts so
basically taking governments and
corporations to task around the Paris
climate Accord agreements through legal
battles and so it turns out like dollars
spent to outcomes had it's like the most
efficient means of getting to the
desired outcome of people actually
adhering to
um climate standards
and I love that as like a metric because
I I tend to think that things that have
their own natural economic flywheel
right and so if you as a philanthropist
are saying okay where is my
where are my dollars best spent in the
climate space like turns out funding
legal action to take corporations to
task for their dirty processes it's like
one of the most efficient things you can
do and like that would be the way that a
venture capitalist might think about it
but the other way that one might think
about it is to say well where do my
dollars go that are severely today like
a space that's basically not economic
and nobody in the near term can figure
out how to make it economic right so
something like
uh there's a project uh here the uh dear
friend of mine sits at the helm of um
Ryan felian and Stewart brand at revive
and restore and they're trying to figure
out how to basically stand up projects
in in de-extinction so bringing
back animals
um implants and and you know coral and
the rest of it that are on the edge or
just past the edge of Extinction
and the vast majority of those things
now technically our startup came out of
that project in an adjacency called
colossal but but by and large most of
these projects are like not economic in
the near term
um and they maybe don't have like a
global impact in the sense that like if
we bring back the black-footed ferret
that's like this you know it's a
meaningful large swath of court or in
the US and it helps solve those
ecosystems but like
does it have its own flywheel is it is
is it a global inflection point you can
make arguments in all directions and so
I think the questions to ask
that a venture capitalists might ask in
in bringing to philanthropy is like
what what can I what like what is the
most efficient use of dollars like is an
interesting way to look at uh
philanthropic questions
I I think another question is just to
say effectively the inverse of that is
to say
what is a completely non-economic thing
uh that I can do to support the the
challenge always becomes in philanthropy
that
um
Charities really suffer when the the
driving force behind them
receipts whether it's because a primary
benefactor passes away and their estate
doesn't continue to support it or
any number of reasons it can happen and
and I think that that's that's the thing
that gives pause and maybe that's the
learning from Venture Capital because
the question that we ask essentially as
investors is what is a little bit of
capital that you can put in that starts
a flywheel
and make something self-sustaining and
that's a real question in philanthropy
are there perhaps opportunities for
bringing previously
non-economic areas of of society into
making them economic so for perhaps with
a now we were talking about
de-extinction perhaps with perhaps
starting with philanthropy this could
become an industry and as soon as you
have something that's in the economic
Arena well then we're we're talking
about a problem that in some sense
solves itself when you have the market
working on it you have the right
incentives and so on is is there an
opportunity to to kick start areas and
bring them into the economic Arena
absolutely right at the end of the day
our markets are based on belief system
our currencies are based on belief
systems every everything in our world is
based on a a societal belief system that
this is worth that much and this trades
for that and this supports all we exist
in these extremely complex emergent
systems and one of the best things that
you can do in in the philanthropy space
is to say okay what what's what's a
belief system that probably needs to
come into being this largely unfounded
today and so they're potentially
in in the climate space for example you
know we have the carbon credit markets
and they're still absolutely nascent but
they're starting to gain Steam and man
if we could just just continue operating
right and a lot of what's happening
there is basically a philanthropic
dollars going into supporting
these climate organizations that are
basically standing up these carbon
markets and saying there's an economic
flywheel to be had here I think the next
iteration of that has to be around kind
of a something like along the lines of
like a diversity like an ecological
diversity credit because uh one could
make the argument that the carbon Market
is the best approximation of that but I
think that there can be perhaps some
perverse incentive structures by only
optimizing around carbon it is necessary
and it's awesome and we should do it and
you know we should all be figuring out
how to better fund and support carbon
markets but like my question is to say
uh what What's the next iteration of
that how how do we support
um more soil diversity and broader
ecological diversity because we know
that those things carried forward
actually have meaningful impacts on the
world right but the better microbial
soil diversity leads to higher crop
yields that helps pollinators and
insects be better supported and then
they in turn again lead to better crop
yields right so all these systems are
flywheels on one another but we need to
figure out how to add economic
inflection points that help bolster
those markets into being
thus philanthropy and venture capital in
a sense blend together if we're talking
about solving the climate the climate
issue or at least
lessening the impacts of climate change
whether you approach that problem from a
VC perspective of trying to fund
startups creating nuclear fusion or
whether you approach it with uh with
philanthropic efforts in carbon credits
and so on you're trying to solve the
same problem so in a sense does it
matter does it matter whether you you
call it philanthropy or whether you
whether you call it a more traditional
investment if you're trying to trying to
get at the same problem I think it does
matter I think motivations are different
you know rightly or wrongly there's an
awful lot of people in the world right
now who are very anti-capitalist systems
um so we should probably just be cogent
around how we present ourselves and
cognizant of those realities
um ideally presenting both sides that
there's actually a middle ground that
we're all trying to streamline towards
and set up you know less less anger and
outrage towards each other
um but I but I actually think that there
is a fundamental difference in saying
um you know even a 15-year fund is not
an nowhere near uh like an
infinite time Horizon right it's 15
years it's a minuscule drop in the
bucket versus I know family offices that
are thinking philanthropically that are
thinking on a multi-generational scale
and that's for me a very different
question so even if they're still pretty
economically minded they have the
capacity and the means uh to think on on
an orders of magnitude larger time scale
and so I I think that it would be a
shame the same way that it's a shame if
the world entirely collapses to same-day
trading markets like I think we we need
every Natural Evolution of of pushing
the framework of long-term thinking to
its edges and I think philanthropy
absolutely sits a tick further on that
timeline you mentioned previously
avoiding investments in technologies
that prey on human Frailty what does
this mean and why is it important
was really fast
you know why is it important you could
make the argument that it's not that
that every human being should learn to
fend for themselves against the ales and
evils potentially that technology could
bring into their lives and that's a
natural form of evolution and
evolutionary pressure and you know we
should stress test our societies and our
governance systems and our democracies
and you know the the strongest will win
and I think that's just an unfortunate
world view for me personally I think
that there are so many things that come
into being that frankly it's not like I
think that the social media companies
had any terribly minded uh predatory
mindsets around them I think a lot of
the things that happened came from a
lack of consideration of a second
daughter effect
uh right what happens when you have an
infinite scroll on a screen well then
you just capture someone's attention
possibly forever right and so we know
that there are
kind of gamified constructs that trap
people
uh gambling is a perfect example
gamification of many things is a perfect
example right it traps our attention it
feeds just enough dopamine back into us
that we stay locked in these loops and
then you basically end up with a lot of
people who are really suffering on the
fringes of society because they don't
have the resources to get out
is there potentially a the reverse of
this so gamification for good absolutely
what are some interesting examples here
have you invested in in any companies
trying to do gamification for good where
perhaps you are you know trying to get
through your to-do list in the best
possible way and you get points or I
don't know is there something like this
we we tend to shy away from Investments
and things that are direct to Consumer
um it's
more of a reflection of us myself and
Steve as individuals than because we
don't believe it's a viable path forward
right we just think that we're not the
best people to think about it but um
yeah I met with an entrepreneur the
other day uh who is doing exactly that
who basically said oh what if we could
the way that Pokemon go actually got
people out you know through an augmented
reality game on their phone running
around in the real world
turns out geotagging lots of things and
generating much higher Fidelity Maps
like what if you could do that in a fun
way and and but with the intention of
getting people moving like physically
moving in space and and getting a little
bit more activity right so turning those
same compelling video games that lock
people in their rooms
and getting them out into the real world
and into happier and healthier bodies so
yeah absolutely I think it's only a
failure of imagination that we frankly
haven't done more of that and you have
this interesting activation barrier
around individual humans right we're
like pretty reticent to get like for to
get off the couch we're kind of energy
saving devices right so given the option
of the go forward or this day lazy path
most people choose to stay lazy so how
do you change
um the the decision making around that
how do you get people to eat healthier
um and and I think that the that we can
we can do an awful lot more around this
um the same way that when we invest in
you know for example anything to do in
the climate space we basically say we
don't believe in altruism no offense
um we just you know it's nice like we
obviously believe in it but like on a
global scale we just think that it's an
unfair request uh particularly of
emerging economies to say
you have a lesser gain but you have this
better long-term outcome like well no
one can make that that's an unfair
position to put somebody in particularly
when the Western world is gotten into
its you know economic uh fertility from
a place of burning an awful lot of
fossil fuels so you have to shift the
economics you have to make the decision
point today economically unquestionable
right so no one's ever going to pay more
for The Greener solution at scale you
have to pay less so that it's not
actually a choice
do you think good ideas are becoming
harder to find are great startups
becoming more rare over time are we have
we picked the low-hanging fruit
I I think we're barely getting started
that's that that's good to hear you
don't think that that perhaps it was
easier to invent something
um that became a great company in the
past in perhaps in the computer industry
because there are so many so many things
that that were available uh where you
could innovate
um and but now kind of the the potential
there has dried up or you see it in
perhaps exactly the reverse word I was
the reverse
over time right for the last 122 years
the amount of compute you can buy for a
dollar
has risen exponentially
for 122 years of like just like a
hundred billion billion uh improvement
over that time which really just means
that the capacity for access to do
interesting things with the resources
you have available
like we've barely scratched the surface
right two-thirds of the world's
population is not actually yet
connected to the internet in a coherent
consistent manner so I I think
when you talk about that
I think anyone who's sitting from the
perspective of like oh we're done or all
of that like that's a very kind of
myopic
Western focused mindset which is to say
we can't even begin to Fathom what the
rest of the world is going to offer us
as opportunities
and I think that's probably coming from
a lot of people from a place of like
like fear but what I'm excited about is
you have all these like all these
sub-Saharan African countries who are
now coming online and have mobile first
economies and are starting to service
their worlds and so I think that the
opportunity space is actually only
growing larger but that's because I
really believe in the capacity of humans
perhaps I should I should frame this
question in another way so think about a
small team uh ideas that are available
to small teams to to iterate on to get
better on and were those ideas easier in
the past so for example I'm if we look
at a long way into the past we can we
can think about uh how easy it was to
invent the light bulb versus how easy it
would be to create a quantum computer or
something because because we are as a
society as a civilization picking the
low-hanging fruit of the technological
tree is it getting diffic more difficult
to find interesting startups no again
resources are becoming becoming more
prolific
more equitable
and you know
Thomas Edison
and the the general electric company and
and you know Nikolai Tesla concurrently
in in their own pathways
it took
quite a number of thousands of years of
civilization to get to a light bulb
right let's just so we're we're actually
just on the accelerating aspect of the
curve and I I think that it's actually
one could one could one could make the
argument that it's getting easier
um because you have a larger swath of
the population
educated sufficiently well in the
precursors such that the general level
of technological literacy across Society
is so thoroughly expanding
that you have a much wider pool set of
creative individuals and teams who are
chipping away at problems now your
question
I could frame as saying is there more
noise in the system today than there was
at some prior point in existence and my
intuition is to say almost certainly yes
right because frankly like who had the
capacity to sit around and pontificate
and be an inventor for the last couple
thousand years of society like such an
outrageously small percentage of society
that it's kind of laughable so in that
sense
it was probably like maybe my job would
have been easier 200 years ago because
there's actually frankly only like 10
people I needed to talk to uh but today
I've talked to thousands of people and
understand what they're working on and
then make some hopefully reasonably
educated decision about which one of
those are likely to work out so I agree
with you that from that perspective that
there's a lot more noise in the system
today but I certainly don't think that
we're we're at some
creative culmination Point such that the
next set of interesting ideas are going
to be harder to come by
I'm actually very happy to hear that
from you from a person who has insight
into these uh aspects okay so there's a
lot of excitement about AI about large
language models generative models all of
this who is going to capture the value
from these models of course it's
difficult to say but what would be your
best guess about whose is it the
hardware manufacturers is it the
existing tech companies is it startups
I'm uncertain and I
try to keep my ear to the ground and
listen to the Groundswell of excitement
and interest and you know the simple
reality is that the Microsoft open AI
partnership is really sufficiently
strong at this point that you go wow
does anybody else really have access to
the same capacity on the same scale and
I can look back through all time and say
and the value accrual almost always
ended up being highly condensed in a
very small independent group that then
ballooned right
um so how does that actually work what
does that look like who builds these
models I think at the end of the day
there there is like different styles of
Valley or cruel in the sense that
you know first and foremost like the the
best chip
like if your audience hasn't read chip
Wars yet highly recommend but you know
turns out we've just further leaned on
our needs around semiconductors and
semiconductor manufacturing and having
these really really high technological
capacity
systems to to build the the highest
forms of compute available and have them
be freely and cheaply available because
like frankly one of the I was sitting
with a with a
um
the top young engineering students at
Stanford last night and I asked them I
did it's kind of the honors engineering
students and I asked them
who here is planning to stay in Academia
because when I was in graduate school
everyone would have raised their hand
uh or maybe one or two kids you know
said oh I'm thinking about and none of
them raised their hands which I thought
was fascinating
and their argument was well really Your
Capacity to innovate and build something
interesting is directly related to your
capacity to have access to compute like
who has the most access to compute it's
actually not the universities anymore
it is largely the large corporations
which is interesting and concerning
right and even for startups like one of
the largest gating factors is basically
like
how many compute modules can you get a
hold of and people are like actually
stockpiling chips I'm not even kidding
it's just a really wild time right now
so I I am worried from an access point
of basically who has access to
these compute models particularly
particularly in a framework where we're
not we're not pushing the bounds of
compute efficiency we're pushing the
balance of like model size
so ah I'm a little scared to say that I
think a lot of the early value accrual
will be in the large corporations but it
will eventually come down those
efficiency curves and then I think it
will get a bit more distributed with
this then if if it happens so that open
Ai and Microsoft in in Partnership
captures a lot of value here would this
be an instance of an existing large
corporation kind of solving this
innovators dilemma or staying on top by
yeah so this is it's not a it's not an
uh an acquisition but it's a it's a
partnership of some sort how does
Microsoft
enable and engage and pull into its own
business lines some of these tools and
and are they well suited to do so from a
government standpoint I have no idea I
don't really know anything about the
underpinnings of Microsoft corporate
structure and style but you know kudos
to them for really making a big bet on a
very turns out strong horse in this
particular race
my sentiment here is that coming from
uh a robotics background I think about
systems that have graceful degradation
and good Fail-Safe mechanisms and
you know I spent a lot of my life
thinking about
um kind of deterministic control systems
and
that feels
still far away from me
in in these systems in these large
language models and so I suppose I
if I listen to everyone around me I I
could come up with opinion saying well
like oh Mariana you're just not paying
enough attention you don't realize how
fast this is getting so much better
um and maybe I'm a bit of a Luddite here
but I think that the initial value
accrual will probably be
in a lot of this like
middle layer software
management tools and you know to anyone
who's saying you know this but these
systems aren't really thinking you could
also counter with and how often are
people really thinking right like
but I am I am very curious I think we
have no idea how to use these systems I
think they're currently very interesting
shiny bobbles of toys that we're picking
up and being very compelled by but I
think we we haven't even begun to
understand how they will actually
influence us in the long run you think
there's a role for philanthropy in
perhaps subsidizing compute for
traditional academic research institutes
if if you could if we could uh have so
one thing Academia as well is doing
things that take it takes a long time is
it requires careful analysis and so on
perhaps one thing that would be very
interesting from a from a safety
perspective of these models is to know
how they work and we don't really know
that even the experts really don't know
how machine learning systems work right
now so perhaps there's a role for
philanthropic funding of of compute for
for Academia
yeah and and one could push the
universities and say why aren't they
putting more of their endowment dollars
to things like this and um
perhaps the a philanthropic access could
be to say you know here are restricted
funds that we will give to your
universities to ask these questions
I I like that as a construct I I think
that's where
the capital markets possibly fall down
is if people have struggled to basically
monetize
philosophical and moral underpinning
questions
right to ask okay well what is the right
construct and how much should we trust
these systems and what does it look like
and
you know if it doesn't make any
near-term economic sense to create
something like an explainable AI then
who on Earth is going to do it and why
and is it necessary I think entirely
relying on an economic system to say oh
all Necessary Things eventually get
borne out I'm not sure I love that so I
I won't I would like to see more people
asking these questions and I mean if
nothing else I would really love to see
someone funding a bunch of
um like political philosophy and moral
and ethical reasoning classes in
computer science schools because I talk
to a lot of very very bright young
people and then I just really want to
hand them like a whole stack of Dead
Philosophers to read because it seems
that they're like divining some of these
principles about like societal and human
reasoning de novo
um and I kind of just want to hand them
like Victor Frankel and say like please
read this
perhaps the the pessimistic perspective
there is that philosophers have been
trying to solve the same problems for
2000 years and haven't really found any
definite uh progress so
why should we expect additional funding
to help
maybe I'm
more philosophically
anchors of our times and how much
they've influenced some of the great
leaders of our times and vice versa like
I don't think the US would exist without
Jefferson
and the kind of sneaker that he was so
so I don't concur with the sentiment
that
um the support of thinking about things
like symbolic reasoning and theories of
mind
don't lead to meaningful outcomes
it's a fascinating example you picked
because that talk about an impactful set
of ideas in the heads of the founding
fathers of the US that allowed basically
a lot of other Innovation including
technical Innovation so I it wasn't the
point wasn't to say that ideas don't
have consequences in the world but
perhaps just that there are some
especially philosophical problems that
are so intractable that we shouldn't
expect to solve them with you know even
with the billions of dollars and and
decades
oh I completely agree with that but I
don't think that's a reason not
turning those Stones over and
I I don't I don't like the line of
reasoning personally to say well that's
really hard and that's not really a
knowable answer so I'm just not going to
worry about it
right I I would rather have everybody be
worried about it and not from generating
a sentiment an underlying sentiment of
anxiety in our world like we have plenty
of that but to say
that we are all responsible
and that there there's a lot of ancient
reasoning to this effect to the fact
that you you are not required to
complete the work nor are you free to be
entirely absolved from it right that's a
a poor rephrasing of the talmud and I I
think it we could probably all stand to
remember things like that how do you
think about the efficient market
hypothesis do you think it's true in
which situations is it true
it's largely true
um I don't know that it's always true
and I think it's only true in spaces
where there's a good representative
market so it's hard the simple reality
is the vast majority of markets aren't
actually free markets they're monopolies
or duopolies hiding in a plain sight and
I think that in that sense we we rarely
actually get to test the efficient
market hypothesis because you don't have
an even playing field of equal
economically minded actors you actually
generally have power highly concentrated
to a handful of individuals or
organizations and and I think in that
sentiment it generally doesn't bear out
to be that true
fantastic all right Mariana thank you
for coming on the future of Life
Institute podcast it's been a real
pleasure to travel on oh such a gift
thank you